the International 2017 grand finals
newbie versus Team Liquid - the winner
goes the ages of Champions to the loser
disappointment and muttered condolences
of maybe next year for a miracle
al-bukhari that disappointment is all
too real at this time last year he had
already been eliminated from the
international
his chance at being the best in the
world was cut short by an upset that no
one could have predicted TNC a team that
barely scraped by was in the loser
bracket all of a sudden they've to owe
them very definitively and we thought
they had the better trap but I just
thought oh gee would be able to pull it
out but at this time things are
different miracle has lost learned and
with a new team by his side has another
shot at greatness miracles journey to
the internationals grand finals was one
that took him through the highs of wins
and two majors and the crushing lows of
defeat at ti6
but before all of that there was a time
when miracle had no idea that dota even
had a pro scene even when I asked him
like me to watch CI 1 2 3
he's like nope never heard of it in fact
a miracle didn't start playing because
he one day dreamed of hoisting the aegis
No our story starts in a net cafe in
Jordan with one simple thing a guy who
loved dota when he was young Amira was
like most kids his age he played soccer
in the streets and spent much of his
time out of the house with his friends
one day he became curious about his
older brothers interest and wanted to
join them on their lengthy trips to the
local net cafes he thought confusing my
mom I want to go with my brothers I want
to see what they do there we start
taking him with us and he started
learning watching only around 12 years
old
Amir quickly got hooked on dota 1 and
his skills grew the local scene dubbed
him miracle boy that moniker later
shortened to just miracle stuck even
after the release of dota 2 miracle
primarily played for fun
solo laddering with intense focus
oblivious to DotA's rapidly growing pro
scene miracle skill increased with time
but he was still just a pub player who
enjoyed the casual aspects of dota when
the official MMR ranking system was
released
in late 2013 miracle had already
achieved an impressive 5.3 K MMR after
hitting 7k solo MMR a little while later
miracle began to realize he could be
among the best carries in the world and
set his goal at becoming the highest
ranked player of all at first I was like
just playing for fun let's say did I hit
8k and then I was like oh [ __ ] like that
there's a small chance
some people might talk to me in-game his
reputation as a serious pop star was
spreading especially after he became
only the second player to hit a k MMR
behind a Lili Rita Omar miracle hoped
that a professional team would contact
him he was ready to prove that he was
more than just a pub star she had a very
brief stint on a smaller team known as
the Balkan Bears but his big chance
truly came when Johan no-tail sunstein
added him on skype at first I actually
thought it's like a fake account and I
was I wasn't really responding but then
I was like alright I'm gonna talk to him
and it was him and I talked to him on
skype and miracle went from pup star to
playing alongside some of DotA's most
respected Talent as a founding member of
OG overnight with veterans like no-tell
and tau fly isaac leaving him miracle
took his first significant steps into
the professional scene though he might
have been ignorant of dota 2's
competitive legacy miracle wasted no
time in making his own mark on the scene
right from the get-go miracle proved
that he was a dominant individual talent
as well as an incredibly flexible and
versatile player to boot the MLG World
Finals was an excellent showcase for
miracle as he not only dominated the
likes of Syed
sumail sumail Hassan and Sergey g-dragon
in lane but carried on a massive variety
of heroes such as queen of pain his
signature anti-mage and even a
Earthshaker by the time the first ever
valve major and frankfurt rolled around
miracle was impressing thanks to
excellent play against top teams
although OG were largely viewed as a
dark-horse
going into the event people were excited
to see if miracle would continue to
perform on a massive stage available he
puts it right to work the tournament
started off on the wrong foot but as the
pressure mounted OG delivered going on
one of the most ridiculous lower bracket
runs and dota 2 history to claim the
title
they fight all the way through the lower
bracket and will be clean the champion
major live here in Frankfort miracle in
particular was lethal on shadowfiend
stunning even when his still unproven
back was against the wall just three
months into his tenure on a professional
team miracle had already claimed a valve
title and was undoubtedly one of the
best players in the world his shy
personality contrasted with his flashy
in gameplay but fans nevertheless
flocked to the game's newest superstar
og and miracle continued to be an elite
force in the dota world for the next
half year winning a number of events and
regularly finishing top four against the
stiffest of competitions a
disappointment at the Shanghai major in
March of 2016 was quickly remedied by a
second valve title this time at the
Manila major three months later his
usual stellar performances only serve to
further the mystique around miracle as
he will see Lee went toe-to-toe against
the best from around the world and
emerged the victor his invoker became a
thing of legend and questions as to
whether or not miracle was only a pub
star were nothing more than a distant
memory but you see a Miracle Network
he's a one-man army I'd say he's a
one-man army technically he's got the
power of magic on his side his faceless
void does he want to mr. Curtis here at
the barman they go to brew my sure
they're trying to get paid support out
there
damnit truths I also beat what even as
his professional career was taking off
one thing had all still remained the
same miracle I played dota with a nearly
unmatched dedication grinding away in
game after game day in and day out his
level of focus is something on
comparable to any player I've ever seen
I've seen a lot of players grow and
become excellent at the game but when he
looks at the screen why he plays it's as
if he's in the game as if he's in the
battlefield in the months following the
Shanghai major he famously became
involved in a race to 9 K MMR with art
or art easy papaya Evil Geniuses star
player then on may 11th 2016 from the
practice rooms at the epicenter 2016
land miracle made history with the 9k
player leading the charge to stellar
results in the months before ti6 og was
touted as a clear favorite to win it all
it was the next step for miracle and the
win at TI would take his already blown
reputation to the next level
[Applause]
jay-j another victory
the loss was a crushing blow to miracle
and a miserable way to cap off his
otherwise brilliant first year of
competitive play while he had already
come so far and achieved so much bombing
out at sea I put a metaphorical
asterisks on his career in fact it was
clearly one of miracles worst
performances ever what kind of wizard
you are that he's figured out that oh
gee would just go from winning Frankfurt
major in Manila major and doing pretty
well in the group stage like they look
like a really strong team and they just
boom out the result called for a change
and on September 16 2016 miracle joined
Team Liquid while liquid started slow
posting mixed results for the rest of
the year it turned out to be a perfect
move for miracle once maroon g8s Mirae
was added to the squad prior to dream
leave season six miracle was surrounded
by a group of tremendously talented
players which took some of the burden to
carry off his shoulders gh and last name
atonement or pillai Ninh would join
miracle in the ranks of the 9k MMR club
and with Curro Curro ki Salahi Tekken
Sony's savvy drafting making full use of
miracles incredibly deep hero pool Team
Liquid had everything they needed to
start winning big tournaments needless
to say liquids run up to TI 7 reflected
their tremendous potential while their
results at DAC 2017 and the kiev major
were disappointing liquid still entered
TI 7 as favourites to win it all but the
fans were still worried what if a liquid
so bad that's okay you can pick him if
you want what a miracle choke under the
pressure once again could he shake the
ghost of TI 6 out of his mind and
playing at the level he was capable of
when the chips were down
thankfully the answer was yes
that's the one they have forget the
fortress they still fortified their love
will fall down by back have to be
committed you've still got another 3k
life on the nation and miracles their
holdings their holdings that doing it
they hate daughters while
one with a tournament high 21 you need
heroes played and some absolutely
stellar games miracle answered those
questions once and for all these scene
teams down Owen one teams that go from
winners to lowers and fall apart under
the pressure miracle has done the exact
opposite liquid who looked shaky after a
winner's bracket loss to Invictus gaming
were an unstoppable freight train by the
tournament's end and finally it was time
miracle that was about to play through
the aegis of champions
newbee versus Team Liquid brand finals
sleep will have to come from the south
the exits out already
miracle spinning inside the pit brushes
down the back wall is guys the best left
for the down
[Music]
[Applause]
heavy damage into Bugis home the retreat
the virus right not hitting the money
macaca has to retreat back out again the
plague was making it difficult the
liquid just to get out of this go
creeping down to beautify now prepare
for catching up baby
the dominant strain
watch that acres of the immortal they
jump in the hole stone from KP caching
to Angus
that doing it's worth the target on he's
dying
the agency mobile the time
[Applause]
gay people bull could rejoice and the
trees but the exes of from SDT happy the
damage I looked into it three heroes
going from Team Liquid to reaction types
is all about miracle de Bergerac Akaka
middle connect follow-up Fitch McAfee
he'll get the son of the medical bill on
the field of new car
[Applause]
my papa
[Applause]
the man who just two years ago
yearn to prove that he was more than a
pub star was staring down the biggest
games of his life what started out as a
simple love for dota had turned into
something different altogether a chance
to be a part of the game to be
immortalized as one of the best to ever
play
[Applause]
who would have thought that the miracle
boy from the net cafes in Jordan who
knew nothing of the International and
prodota would become a two-time major
winner a TI champion and one of the
game's most popular figures it just goes
to show what can happen with dedication
focus and the will to be the best at the
end of the day his love of the game
isn't going anywhere and neither is
miracle after all there's majors to win
a TI title to defend and of course dota
to be played and we wouldn't have it any
other way
thanks for watching our telling of
miracles story
it's an incredible pleasure to share
with you the outstanding story of such
an inspiring player is there a story
you'd like to see us tell let us know in
the comments below and be sure to
subscribe for more great content